blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so we had a mass shooting
yesterday you might say david that's not
rare in the united states mass shootings
are very common and you would be
completely correct so i guess what i
mean is we had a mass shooting yesterday
in the united states
that rose to a level of getting some
national attention on the 4 5 6 7 p.m
news when we were uh doing a live stream
yesterday covering a number of different
things
news of this mass shooting at a shopping
mall
in boise idaho
started to
sort of percolate through national media
and we now have more details about it
but as i always do anytime we talk about
a specific mass shooting i take it as an
opportunity to remind you and myself
that mass shootings in the united states
are very common and shootings in general
ones that don't count as mass shootings
but just shootings in general are
incredibly common and in fact yesterday
there were a number of mass shootings
and 57 known shootings that got at least
some media coverage 57 yesterday
and most of us
if we heard about any of them
heard only about the one shooting in
boise idaho so let's start with what
happened in idaho police say two dead
and four are injured in this idaho mall
shooting a suspect is in custody after
two people were killed and four injured
including a police officer
in a shooting at a shopping mall on
monday
authorities said officers exchanged
gunfire with the suspect police on
monday evening said in a news release
that the suspect was in critical
condition at a hospital the officer who
was hurt was treated and released
as of this morning
we don't know more
about the victims officer or suspect
although i suspect maybe by the time
today's show is published more will be
known the mall was secured by monday
evening it would remain closed for now
boise police chief ryan lee said the
shooting was reported around 1 50 p.m
monday that's um you know cup i don't
remember if idaho is on mountain or
pacific time but that would make it 350
or 450 on the east coast including a
report that one person was shot and down
at that time when officers arrived they
spotted someone matching the description
of the suspect there was an exchange of
gunfire
last night the police chief said we
can't really comment more
i don't know that there's much more to
say about this particular shooting so
where does that get us well reminder the
ones that make national news are the
tiniest tiny minority so for example
yesterday you can go to gun violence
archive dot org and you will see that
there were 57
different shootings
with specific reporting meaning we have
incident information and we have at
least a news source
and you could just go through and look
oh in elgin or elgin illinois there was
a shooting with one killed and two
injured
in um de ball texas there were two
people injured and you just go through
and it's pages and pages three people
injured in charlotte north carolina at a
shooting
one killed one injured in kansas city
kansas it's all over the country
and it's pages and pages and 57
different shootings yesterday with
specific reporting you can pick any of
these i don't know memphis tennessee and
look at a source
parents rally in memphis after shooting
sends three teens to the hospital every
single one of these is a story with
people and families and friends and
communities affected every single one
there were 57 yesterday you go back i
mean just let's pick another one um
tulsa oklahoma where one person was
killed let's look at that
deadly shooting investigation at south
tulsa apartment complex this one was at
an apartment complex
um every single one of these is a story
and then you say well david sir those
are not all mass shootings and you would
be right but then you can actually go
and you can look at the mass shootings
as well and yesterday there were three
the boise idaho mass shooting is one
where two people were killed and six
injured in memphis tennessee there was a
mass shooting with four people injured
and then in winston-salem north carolina
winston i hope i pronounced that right
winston-salem north carolina one person
killed and three people injured every
single day
um
you can find dozens and then usually
three to a handful of mass shootings
and
we have so many people who you know
there's just no way to prevent it it's
it's it's crazy we
we really can't do anything and yet
this is the country
at our level of development and our
level of wealth okay i know people will
say david look at liberia
okay i don't know it's really a
comparison to the united states in many
many different ways
but
there's people who say it's just we just
can't figure out what to do there's
really no way to prevent this
and yet it's really only happening here
the unique combination
of widespread availability of guns
very lacks
gun safety regulations
and this is the x factor remember
this
fetishizing of gun culture
seeing guns as a way to solve
interpersonal problems
and
lack of access to or stigmatization of
mental health care it's all these
different things it's sort of like a
horrible combination
in the united states of a cultural
aspect
some economic aspects and public health
aspects all coming together really
really horrifying uh but that's the
latest one shooting that made the news
there were three mass shootings
yesterday and 57 shootings that we know
of based on at least some reporting
uh joe biden is apparently apparently
standing firm
and saying
no
donald trump i am not going to exert
executive privilege over documents that
you don't want made public
or made available to investigators
because they relate to your possible
wrongdoing
leading up to and on january 6 2021 the
day of the trump riots this is again
what job i we'll see if he stands firm
indefinitely but for now joe biden is
saying no
cnn was the first to report the biden
white house is again rejecting more
executive privilege claims by donald
trump reported on by caitlin collins and
paul leblanc or leblanc could be either
president joe biden has once again
refused to assert executive privilege
over more documents that former
president donald trump has sought to
keep out of the hands of the committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the u.s capitol
according to a letter obtained by cnn
white house counsel dana remus informed
national archivist david ferriero on
monday that biden would not assert
privilege over additional materials that
trump requested remain secret as a
matter of executive privilege trump is
going bonkers trying to keep this stuff
private as the article says
trump already filed a lawsuit to stop
the national archives the custodian of
his administration's white house records
from giving documents to congress that
he believes are privileged
and the latest documents will likely
become part of the lawsuit the national
archives is set to begin turning over
records to the house on november 12th
unless trump gets a court order that's a
couple weeks from now
remus wrote president biden has
considered the former president's
assertion and i have engaged in
consultations with the office of legal
counsel at the department of justice
president biden has determined
that an assertion of executive privilege
is not in the best interests of the
united states and thus therefore is not
justified as to the documents provided
to the white house on september 16 and
september 23. accordingly president
biden does not uphold the former
president's assertion of executive
privilege
this is sort of like um
trying to use your employee discount
after you no longer work at the company
it's just not up to trump at this point
in time and trump really really doesn't
like that he wants it to be up to him he
wants to be able to shield these
documents now a couple of important
notes one
this has sort of been like par for the
course with trump
is this how an innocent person behaves
is this how an innocent person behaves
that's
a regular question we've asked with the
former trump administration number two
executive privilege and classified are
not the same thing
there are people who either out of
ignorance or out of bad faith are saying
why won't biden keep these things
classified as they should be it's
irresponsible for biden to declassify
no no no no
it was trump
who spilled classified information to a
russian spy recruiter in the oval office
remember that what were you saying at
the time sir or ma'am
and uh privileged and classified are two
different things executive privilege is
there to make sure
that things can be openly discussed by
members of an administration
with a degree of confidentiality
because sometimes if everything that's
discussed is public it affects your
ability to have a functioning government
that's not
the same thing as this is just
classified information
and can there be executive privilege
asserted over things that were
classified or not of course you can have
overlap between these two groups imagine
a venn diagram executive privilege
classified okay we are not talking about
here as far as we know
we are not talking about classified
information so cut it okay either you're
wrong or you're just trying to fool us
with your bad faith argumentation but
it's neither um joe biden needs to hold
steady on this if trump claims he did
nothing wrong there should be nothing to
hide just carry on
that's it trump has no say here now
on the tail end of this
could some i'm i would never recommend
this
never you you guys know me i would never
recommend this but
sometimes documents leak
here we're talking about trump wanting
to prevent these documents from getting
in the hands of the committee
investigating the january six riots
that's what we're talking about right
now not about them getting out to the
public
sometimes things leak
and if they did it would be very
interesting i'm not suggesting anyone
leak anything but sometimes that happens
and it really triggers donald trump now
last thought on this consider this
really funny contrast
to his supporters donald trump insists
i didn't do anything wrong
and i am under no obligation
to
give anything to these witch-hunt people
these are witch hunts and they're just
trying to go after your favorite
president uh i have all the power
they can't take it from me i don't have
to give him anything meanwhile he's
privately going to joe biden saying
please don't release the documents joe
please don't release the documents
that's your big alpha donald trump that
these people pray at the altar of just a
contrast to keep in mind do you think
here's my my question
do you think joe biden will hold steady
on this
and not
assert executive privilege as requested
by donald trump i'm optimistic that he
will let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at d pacman we'll be
right back
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
all right we are going to take a tour
today it's not going to be
a fun tour i i'm not going to lie this
is not exactly touring unesco world
heritage sites and
amazing architecture and sites and views
and these different things landscapes
this is going to be
a tour
through madness quite frankly
the world is increasingly horrified by
the anti-vaccine madness happening
across the united states in media
at school board meetings at rallies and
at other places now many of you would
rightly point out there have been
anti-vaxx elements in many countries
around the world and you would be right
but the combination of the united states
being one of the countries that first
had access to as many vaccines as we
could possibly want
and being one of the largest and most
powerful countries in the world combined
with the degree of wide-ranging
anti-vaccinist insanity
is getting a lot of negative attention
for us it's humiliating it's
embarrassing that this is what the
united states is being known for so
let's start the tour first
there was an
anti-vaccine mandate
uh march
in new york city
and this we're just these are anecdotes
we're just dropping in here's one guy
who says that the mandates are orwellian
and like nazi germany which is remember
we did our story last week
anti-vaxxerism and coveted conspiracies
push people towards anti-semitism one
element of that
is the trivialization of the holocaust
because
vaccine requirements that you can test
out of or like if you want to work here
you should go and get a vaccine
otherwise you're going to have to test
your leave that's not what the nazis
were doing to the jews okay very very
different to
to
say we do not comply to what's going on
with these mandates you know uh this
stuff is orwellian it's uh it's it's
totally uh nazi germany type stuff and
so
uh you know we're just done with it
right it is not
orwellian and it is not nazi germany
type stuff um it's just it's just not uh
this same guy was again we don't know
who this guy is just just iran it
doesn't matter is the point it this is a
guy random anti-vaccine activist who's
been infected with this stuff
of course connected all of it to the
democratic party and said this is all
about what the dems want make you weak
make you dependent destroy the country
this is a widespread narrative among the
right take a look the democrat platform
is founded on this garbage it's founded
on destruction it's founded on on making
us weak making us dependent making us uh
uh you know
just
destroying our country right so the
destruction of the country narrative
make you weak make you dependent on the
government
likening to nazi germany which is a
trivialization of the holocaust it's
checking all the boxes and most of the
world and more than half of the united
states sees this and says
do these people not realize how
humiliating and embarrassing this is
this this is absolutely wild
then just going to something totally
different
here's naomi wolfe naomi wolf is
off the deep end i don't know how many
of you are familiar with naomi wolf when
i was in college there would be many
classes where we would see clips of neo
communications courses we would see
clips of naomi wolf making interesting
critiques and analyses she seems
completely off the deep end and she says
the only people ever
subjected to mandatory vaccinations were
slaves what naomi yeah that's what she
says coercing people to have a
vaccination we've never had that in the
united states in our entire history
unless you were an enslaved person now
that's not true
i have no idea where naomi wolf gets
that idea
but
uh
right now
all 50 states plus dc mandate
immunization for a number of conditions
to go to public schools uh diphtheria
tetanus pertussis polio measle you know
there's a long history of vaccine
requirements um i just some of these
things are so stupid
that you don't even really know what
they mean because it's so obviously
untrue but now naomi wolf is being held
up as some kind of oracle by some on the
right people who by the way would never
listen to naomi wolfe ever ever ever uh
before
very very strange
then we go to a california high school
teacher this is now going to the school
board part so we've done rally anti-vaxx
back uh rally
we then did um right-wing media that was
like the war room or you know one of
those real america's voice the thing
steve bannon's on and we heard from
naomi wolfe now we're going to school
board here's a california high school
teacher who says he will fight the
mandate no matter what it ha what
happens he might lose his job because he
answers to god and his wife now his wife
maybe anti-vaxx i have no reason to
believe that if god exists god is
anti-vaxx i'm still not really aware of
any religion that's just flat out no
vaccines let's take a listen to this guy
i'm willing to fight this mandate for my
family and my community if it means i
lose my job i'll be able to sleep at
night knowing i stood up for freedom and
i'm certain that history will say that
i'm on the right side of science's will
i only answer to god
my wife not the government
and look at the cheering and the fist
pumping and the usa chant
it's actually hard to think of anything
more anti-american than what that guy is
doing i mean truly truly uh now we will
go from a school board meeting remember
it's a tour through the insanity we're
now going to the floor of the house of
representatives here is congressman long
with some very strange comparison
between the military requiring vaccines
and i think he's talking about new coke
take a listen see if you can figure it
out
1886 a product was brought online
coca-cola and it remained one of the
most popular products of all time until
1985 99 years later and they came out
with a great idea new coke right problem
is new coke was a terrible that's the
problem
idea
and three months later they brought back
what they call classic coke because of
this terrible terrible idea that had to
be fixed making our military be
vaccinated against their will is a
terrible terrible idea that needs to be
fixed now the funny thing is it's not a
new idea there have been vaccination
requirements in the military
for a really i don't even know how long
for a really long time they're just
adding the covet 19 vaccine as happens
when new vaccines are developed
they get added as requirements for the
military the really funny thing is it's
nothing like new coke actually
i don't want to go on a whole tangent
in business school
we did a case study on new coke new coke
is a really interesting business case
study actually uh there was also another
one i think like pepsi clear it tasted
like pepsi but it looked it was
transparent and i think that also failed
um in any case very interesting business
discussion about new the history of new
coke the analogy to a vaccine
requirement for the military simply not
there um then oh this is really
interesting so then on fox news
they talk about a clip of cdc director
rochelle walensky
saying we need to educate people about
the vaccine so they become comfortable
going and getting it they need to learn
about the vaccine and fox news acts as
if what she's talking is about
re-education
alluding to re-education camps and
dictatorships but rachelle wolenski
didn't say it take a look at this
mayor de blasio has warned city workers
if they don't get the vaccine by friday
they will be put on unpaid leave and now
the cdc is planning to quote educate
those who are hesitant to get the shot
here's cdc director rachelle
we believe it is very important to get
these people vaccinated there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need so that they are feeling
comfortable in getting vaccinated
something about the phrase re-education
she didn't say re-education you notice
what they did there she didn't say
re-education she just said we've got to
educate people about the science of the
vaccine and get these people on board
seems uh pretty strikingly similar to a
really tragic chapter in our globe's
history i get i don't know what i don't
know if she's talking about
uh
slavery or the holocaust it's not even
clear what she's referring to but it's
crazy and then they build on this they
just continue building building building
on it even though it was it rochelle
wallenski said we've got to educate
and the host says re-education whoa and
they just keep going harris part of what
is so troubling is the notion of that
again the reprogramming and education
where she never said reprogramming that
i mean
they're they they came up with that out
of thin air you are automatically
branded an enemy you are automatically
branded frankly a criminal in some
sectors if you dare to even question if
you dare to
to expect what we were promised so you
get it they they introduced the term
re-education which rachelle wallensky
didn't
and uh here is tommy
tommy lauren uh saying she's so proud of
people standing up against this i'd also
like to say this when we see this
protest in brooklyn and we see these
workers standing up when i saw those
images nothing made me feel more proud
to be an american because i saw
americans of every color every shape
every size every gender and probably
every political affiliation standing
together in the name of freedom that's
american as it gets yeah so you guys get
the idea an absolute humiliation
globally for the united states it's
everywhere it's on right-wing media it's
on the floor of the house it's at
rallies it's everywhere and um i don't
think it's going away anytime soon let's
now talk about something
opposite this when it comes to vaccines
so listen i am not like a big neil
cavuto fan neil cavuto's been a fox news
host for a really long time maybe since
the start of the network he's been he's
been there for a very long time
um i often disagree with him on politics
neil cavuto is immunocompromised he has
multiple sclerosis
uh he has had heart surgery
he is vaccinated and neil cavuto on fox
news is saying
get vaccinated
he's begging he's saying the political
stuff around this it's got stop go and
get vaccinated he's begging people to
get vaccinated and he's being ignored by
his entire network uh
of evening hosts including tucker
carlson and laura ingram the fox and
friends people it's like he's shouting
into a void
um here he is
i mean i'll just play the clip and it's
it you this is it's a lone voice on fox
news take a listen to this i feel very
strongly and i know we live in this
hyper you know politicized age that
people get vaccinated i i i know you
know a lot of people say that's a
private decision i get that i appreciate
that but i'd like to urge people of all
sorts please get vaccinated yeah he's
saying it's a private decision and the
decision that would make most sense for
you to make is to go and get vaccinated
which is perfectly reasonable and in
line with this freedom ideology uh this
situation for me uh being an immuno
compromise half the cases that we're
we're hearing on the breakthrough front
are among the amino compromised people i
should mention the context is also that
neil cavuto
uh contracted kovid and he believes he
had a relatively mild case despite being
immunocompromised because he's
vaccinated like me who've had you know
and have multiple sclerosis or prior
heart situation or cancer uh there are
many like that all around us and mine is
not a secret at fox
but there are plenty of people working
around you howie uh and at fox and all
types of business environments wow who
are susceptible to this sort of thing
you can help them out a lot if whatever
your views on mandates and i get that no
one likes to be ordered to but in the
end if you can get vaccinated and think
of someone else and think of what that
could mean to them and their
survivability from something like this
will all be better off this is eminently
reasonable who can disagree with any
word of what neil cavuto is saying but
the context is fox news and he's
screaming into a void here's one more
clip
um and he's saying toss the politics
around this please lost 5 million
globally to this we've lost nearly 800
000 in the us
take the political speaking points and
toss them for now i'm begging you toss
them and think of what's good not only
for yourself but for those around you if
you don't want to do it for yourself if
you think it's a pain in the ass i get
that right but think of others around
you i dare say people who experience
this or seen loved ones who've been
affected by this or have never died from
this are not judging the wisdom of
mandates they're wishing they got
vaccinated and they didn't right uh neil
cavuto quite literally begging saying
i'm i'm begging you supplicating neil
cavuto
and he's on fox news and they're
ridiculing the mask mandates they're
attacking the mask mandates they're
talking about authoritarian all this
crazy stuff uh neil cavuto's right we
don't have to agree with him on
everything but on this issue he is the
most sensible voice on fox news now
remember
when trump was president brian kilmeade
was doing interviews with trump i just
reviewed one where they were both just
talking about how great the vaccines are
everybody should get him because at the
time it was wow thank you president
trump for making the vaccine times have
changed and now we're down to neil
cavuto we'll have more coverage of this
insanity on the david pakman show
instagram find it at david pakman show
on instagram we'll be right back
forget that the best way to support the
david pakman show is by becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials you also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i'm really glad to see that more and
more
of fox news hosts are being confronted
with the hypocrisy of their going
completely crazy about the vaccine
mandates that are being put in place by
various companies while not mentioning
that fox news itself actually has a
stricter mandate than that which most
companies have and that which was
proposed by joe biden for companies of
100 or more employees so yesterday we
had this clip from fox and friends where
they completely unbelievably said we
don't have a mandate we have a protocol
we looked at the definition of the word
mandate we looked at the definition of
the word protocol and we determined uh
they have both it's it's the same thing
it's a distinction without a difference
it's a difference without a distinction
whatever word or phrase you want to
apply to it uh it was bs and it was not
believable today we're going to go and
look at another one of these
confrontations and this one is with
tucker carlson
now this one's really interesting
because tucker carlson has been one of
the most
sort of prominent
purveyors
of the attacks on vaccine requirements
even saying the vaccines don't even
really seem to work and the vaccines
might have killed thousands of people
and all these different things media
matters has a great article on this fox
personalities trying to distance
themselves from fox's vaccine mandate
even though fox news's requirements for
unvaccinated workers are stricter than
those recommended by the biden
administration network hosts continue to
attack vaccination policies and
compliance protocols fox personalities
and guests have insisted the mandates
and testing requirements are akin to jim
crow laws
apartheid
eugenics
forced sterilization
and discrimination against those
affected by hiv aids
the biden administration policies fox
has spent months demonizing
require companies with 100 or more
employees to ensure that staff is
vaccinated or test weekly
fox corporation's policy is get
vaccinated or test daily
and enter your status into an online
portal more than 90 percent of fox
employees report being vaccinated okay
so now
um
[Music]
this is great this is a clip from save
the nation vincent jason
and they bring this to tucker carlson on
october 13th he does this maniacal laugh
take a look at this okay so i i have a
question here about fox news um
yeah you said fox news has no vaccine
mandate but according to newsweek the
company requires unvaccinated employees
to submit to daily covid testing which
is stricter than biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing right
businesses that employ more than 100
people is fox news denying the civil
liberties
of its employees by being stricter than
president biden fair i don't know i mean
you should probably ask newsweek it
sounds like they got a pretty precise
handle on what's happening
right so that's not a serious answer all
right but let's continue hey
if it's wrong let me know if i'm wrong
no
yeah
it's
it's completely wrong as i noted the
other night um i'm not
you know so what is the policy
for the company
um on this but as an employee so that's
that's just that's just you know bs
as an employee he could speak to his
understanding of the policy he's
subjected to i mean he's subjected to
the policy so you don't have to speak
for the company because i don't run the
company and i'm not
you know i'm just an employee of the
company um
my personal tell us as an employee the
policy you've been subjected to and that
you've agreed to reference is that fox
news
would you know
make a statement about what its policies
are but i think like a lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and a lot with
much higher mortality rates than covid19
true and you know there's hiv of course
there's tuberculosis of course there are
a bunch of different varieties of
hepatitis which have killed
many hundreds of thousands of americans
over the years et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and employers are not empowered in fact
they're not allowed to ask employees
what their status is are you hiv
positive really can you be test should
we test people so notice that this is
this is now
a gish gallop
okay there's no vaccine for hiv
first and foremost okay
secondly we're talking about asking
employees vaccination status not disease
status
number three
hiv is far less contagious than covet
it's a sexually transmitted disease it's
i hope people understand the way in
which this is a verbal ink plot there's
no real substantive answer here based on
their sexual but hiv isn't a
communicable disease in the same way
like
you can't you can't sneeze on somebody
and give them hiv right because he has
killed has killed tens of millions oh
yeah
now that's a different now now notice
how the goal posts are different
the death toll of hiv over
40 years now is different than how
contagious it is
it also i mean
you can't just walk by someone and they
sneeze and you have hiv
um this is really i don't think tucker
is this stupid so i think this is just
bad faith
i don't doubt that but you can't it's
not a communicable disease in the same
way you have to have sex or share blood
correct
well sure
at which point you
transmit it so it is by definition
communicable yeah and he said it's not
communicable in the same way and he's
right not in his communicable in the
same way
that's my point just to be clear
i am
totally opposed to asking anybody his
hiv status
so now
look at what he's doing
this is a it's really a clinic in
disinformation now tucker is saying he's
against the thing he mentioned
which is not even analogous to covet
vaccination status he now says
kobe so he's he said covet vaccination
status is analogous to asking hiv status
and he's against he's not saying ask
people hiv step
we're not even talking about the same
thing anymore the first question was
doesn't your company have a stricter
policy than the one biden suggests which
tucker got out of by saying
listen i don't i don't speak for fox
news
i'm totally opposed to asking his
prostate cancer status
or what prostate cancer now now we're in
now we're in lulu you know looney land
uh when we now with pr
prostate cancer hiv is communicable
through flu
through sexual contact sexual fluids
blood
now with prostate cancer what are we
even talking about this has nothing to
do with medical privacy his you know
latest blood sugar levels are we have
hipaa laws for a reason so i'm hired to
do a job
and now now raising hipaa hipaa has
absolutely nothing to do with this
whatsoever so
look at the way in which tucker is
unable to give any serious answer
fox's policy is stricter than the one
biden proposes tucker first says i don't
speak for fox news no but you're an
employee you could tell us what they
told you you could tell us what decision
you made about going with it in order to
continue working there that's number one
he doesn't answer
then he goes into
hiv
then he goes into hiv status versus
vaccination status
then prostate cancer
then hipaa this is not about hipaa hipaa
has to do with the transmission of
medical records and privacy by medical
providers we're off the deep end folks
so
look at how quickly he fell apart under
just basic questioning okay i'm not
going to spend a ton of time on this but
i did want to briefly
play a clip for you that has gone
completely viral some of you might
remember the film passion of the christ
i didn't see the film i just don't care
a passion of the christ was this movie
where i actually don't remember whether
mel gibson's anti-semitic incident with
california police happened before or
after his production or direction of
passion of the christ but passion of the
christ combined with
um the anti-semitic police incident with
mel gibson
sort of told us wow mel gibson's really
off the deep end
the actor in passion of the christ was
right winger jim caviezel
jim caviezel appeared at a q anon
conference over the weekend and appeared
to have a complete meltdown going into
another planet um jim caviezel emulates
braveheart speech to cheering crowd at q
anon convention reports newsweek
the passion of the christ star jim
caviezel evoked mel gibson's famous
battle cry from the movie braveheart
during a speech at a q anon convention
in las vegas nevada
cavisel 53 made reference to the 1995
film during a speech at the for god and
country patriot double down convention
doesn't that sound like a fun family
friendly event
the actor repeated word for word the
famous battle cry william wallace gave
to scottish soldiers ahead of their do
or die battle against the english he
then added we must fight for authentic
freedom
it underpinned a speech that mentions
child sex trafficking an issue at the
core of q anon conspiracies as well as a
fight against satan and liberal values
uh let's take a look at the video i
would get the kids out of the room for
this one here's jim caviezel appearing
to lose his mind will you fight this man
says no we'll run and we'll live
yep fight you may die
run and you live
for at least a while
and dying in your beds many years from
now would you have been willing to trade
all the years from this day to that for
one chance this is a very sick person
just one chance to come back here and
tell our enemies
that you can take our lives but you can
never take our freedom every man dies
not every man truly lives you you you
you we must fight for that authentic
freedom is he also doing like a slight
scottish accent in on top of like this
is crazy and live my friends by god we
must live and with the holy spirit as
your shield and christ is your sword may
you join saint michael and all the
angels and defending god and setting
lucifer and his head smith straight
right back to hell where they belong
i thought he said guccifer i thought it
was this was a different speech for a
moment
reminder this is the for god and country
patriot double down
q event
in vegas this weekend
we are headed into the storm of all
storms
yes
this storm is upon us
but not without jesus our rudder
and in the words of reagan
evil is powerless if the good run of
faith god bless you
so that's getting a standing ovation
that's considered good
by
a contingent of the american population
that number one would raise questions
about a psych eval
in most contexts number one
number two
the world sees this and says what the
hell is wrong in the united states right
now
um it is a level of
wackiness and
fanaticism
and um i i i'm kind of at a loss for
words actually
um
and it is a really
just kind of scary time
um a little more from the summary
cavizel ended his nearly 20 minute long
speech
by using a term that features
prominently in cuban on lore and you we
just heard that we are headed into the
storm of all storms yes the storm is
upon us
um q anon followers share a belief that
former president trump would order mass
arrests of members of elite cabal
in a day called the storm it didn't
happen
they baselessly believe a satanic
cannibalistic cabal made up of
celebrities democrat politicians and
government officials is involved in a
global child sex trafficking ring
um
oh this is funny
funny it's horrifying but funny cavisel
previously pushed the q anon conspiracy
that a chemical compound called
adrenochrome
is being harvested from trafficked
children
in april cavisel told conspiracy we
should call them conspiracy delusionists
at a conference in oklahoma about the
untrue conspiracy while speaking about
his upcoming moving sound of freedom the
movie is based on the life of
self-described anti-human trafficking
activist timothy ballard
kaveisl said when you are scared
you produce adrenaline if you're an
athlete you get in the fourth quarter
you have adrenaline that comes out of
you if a child knows he's going to die
his body will secrete this adrenaline
they have a lot of terms that they use
that he takes me through it's the worst
horror i've ever seen the screaming
alone even if i never ever saw it it's
beyond and these people that do it there
will be no mercy for them
um
really really crazy stuff let's just
very quickly look at just a little bit
of that
uh adrenochrome i think this is the key
moment
you said
you said a word
a minute ago and i i want to clarify
what that word was because you said a
word yeah and i want to make sure that
you said adrenochrome
yeah
and a lot of people here there's about 4
500 people here there's uh about a half
million people streaming online sure
having some cyber attacks that feed's
been going on and off it's it's a cyborg
but you said that word and by show hands
who's heard that word before in this
building could you please explain to the
extent that you want to or not want to
what that is because some people have
never heard that yeah you may want to
keep this a secret jim and we need to
discuss that
essentially
you have adrenaline in your body i'll
just simplify it and and when you are
scared you produce adrenaline if you're
an athlete you get in the fourth quarter
you have adrenaline that comes out of
you
if a child knows he's going to die
his body will
secrete this
adrenaline
and they have a lot of terms that they
use that he takes me through but um
it's the worst horror i've ever seen is
screaming alone even if i never ever
ever ever saw it
okay so anyway completely out of his
mind guys uh there's jim caviezel i
guess new uh new q anon hero horrible
horrible stuff we'll take a quick break
and be right back with much more today
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right next i want to
look at a very strange interview that
republican congresswoman lauren beaubert
gave to
dave rubin now some in the audience are
familiar with dave rubin summer not dave
rubin's former tyt young turks host who
was ostensibly on the left he had a
political awakening around the age of um
40 years old close to 40 years old which
some don't believe is genuine some
believe is based in audience capture
grifting and financial incentives up to
others to determine that uh he is now
very very after kind of playing that
he's the last real liberal role for a
few years he now is on the right he's a
right winger he said he's okay being
called a right-winger
he says he voted for trump
he
um
you know etc etc and he gives an
interview that would make north korean
propaganda newscasters blush i mean
really we're going to look at this
interview and there's sort of a couple
of different types of context here one
is
we just learned about lauren bobert's
alleged role in planning the january
sixth trump riots that she or staffers
were involved in talking to the
organizers along with others we talked
about this rolling stone article
yesterday that's one context here and
then the second context is again just
like the brazen and embarrassing nature
of this interview um altogether so let's
just get into the first clip and this is
just again this is like the cultural
stuff here's lauren bobert saying um
because of the mask mandates she's
pulling her kids right out of school and
now is partially home schooling i just
pulled my kids out of public school
because they brought back mask mandates
and they're not letting up on it and i
said okay well we're doing something
else because i'm not subjecting my
children to this again
and uh and so we're we're pulling them
out and doing something on our own but
are you homeschooling now it'll be a
hybrid version of homeschooling it's a
hybrid she'll be hybrid homeschooling is
it good for kids who presumably have
community at school who presumably have
some friends at school etc to be told
little johnny
little susie
you're not gonna wear a mask now you're
gonna sit at home and we're gonna teach
you it's hybrid who knows what they
really mean like is that even good for
the kid i don't know
but it doesn't seem super great
then
lauren bobert blames nancy pelosi for
division in the house it's not that
republicans have stopped even pretending
to be about policy and obstructing
anything democrats want to do it's not
that republicans are totally
hypocritical on every issue gladly
voting for trump's covet relief
but then when biden is in voting against
it even though it's very similar it's
just a few months later um but she says
it's nancy pelosi's fault and uh ruben
just he's on board with all of it there
was there's just no challenging of
anything she says they keep us so
divided and so separate and
previous
members of congress who have been there
previously they'll tell you it's never
been this way
there was always communication between
republicans in democracy now part of she
may be right that it's never been this
way but it's this we've never had such
weaponized outrageous
trumpian members of congress making it
this way
and now it is so divided and that's by
design
she wants to keep us separate she wants
the house chambers empty
you're talking about you're talking
about nancy nancy pelosi yes yes and and
she truly believes this is pelosi's
house not yeah and reuben's just nodding
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is a propaganda interview this is
what you would expect to see on that
north korean channel
or on you know venezuelan state media or
whatever it's that it's what it is um
here as if this is funny lauren bobert
smiles and laughs at the idea that
they've installed metal detectors at the
house
because of her as if it's something to
be proud of
nancy pelosi has called me the enemy
within
we have metal detectors outside of the
house chambers because of me
and uh
so so it seems yeah
if uh
you know if your employer
has had to institute
security measures as a result of your
actions
it's not something i'd be cheering about
imagine if remember my circuit city days
that i've talked about uh so
nostalgically on the program imagine if
when i worked at circuit city
circuit city installed metal detectors
that employees had to go through
because of me because of something i did
and then i bragged about it
that's what she's doing
that's how outrageous this has gotten
um and then they get into i guess what
you would call something more
substantive even though it's not
substantive because reuben doesn't even
question it lauren bobert says her
objection to the electoral college
results being counted
was that it violated the constitution
and reuben's just nodding
i objected to the electoral college
results because the constitution was
violated right and that's our biggest
threat right now is the complete
disregard of the constitution now the
constitution was not violated
all of these talking points have been
widely debunked as usual it's hard to
understand the exact argument they're
making sometimes they say well it was
unconstitutional and it's not she's
saying federal constitution some say
state it was unconstitutional that
states changed election procedures
without
legislation that's actually no big deal
rebecca greene an election law professor
at the college of william and mary said
it is often the case that there are gaps
in election statutes that state and
local election officials routinely fill
according to their authority so to say
that all decisions about how elections
are run must emanate from the
legislature is not consistent with
delegated authority to state election
officials it's a lie
that it's unacceptable to change
election rules without legislation in
states
they're repeating it but it's just not
true
then
many states changed election practices
because of the pandemic that includes
blue states that includes red states it
includes states in which trump won it
includes states in which biden won big
shocker they only care about the fact
that it was done in states that biden
won so north dakota red state trump won
changed voting rules due to the pandemic
you don't hear a peep out of these
people
arkansas or arkansas as some used to say
arkansas
red state trump won changed election
rules due to the pandemic what they
never mentioned arkansas
texas they all made changes in this way
on the basis of the pandemic trump won
all three republicans don't say a word
about it this stuff makes us look like a
joke this woman is one of 435 members of
congress we are a global laughingstock
because of people like her and reuben
like a bobble head nodding along just
nodding along
uh it's embarrassing folks it's a i'm
i'm embarrassed for both of them i'm
blushing
for both of them
um just a little final note on the uh
trump executive privilege stuff and just
trump's state of mind right now
we haven't talked about this for months
because
it just hasn't been newsworthy but
donald trump continues to publish
uh trash uh agit trash i think is the
way i would refer to it on his uh
website donaldjump.com
just so you know what's happening and if
you don't care that's fine but just so
you know what's happening
donald trump published seven statements
yesterday to his uh to his news page
um
look at some of these in case you missed
it new immigration numbers prove biden
border crisis is worst in history
no surprise and it's a link to an
article with the right wing federalist
later in the day
in case you missed it newt gingrich
interviews molly hemingway on the rigged
election lays out a very clear case for
the very rigged and corrupt presidential
election we're almost a year out folks
he's still going
post number three yesterday
gop pollster predicts trump would beat
biden or harris in a landslide right now
link to new york post article new york
post of course fox news news corporation
same company
trump posts an article
the confusing mr biden
it's like his blog
in case you missed it biden has no
answers to the nation's problems except
empty promises another new york post
article
another post trump u.s being poisoned by
illegal immigrants crossing the border
from the new york post
in case you missed it explosive
revelations in wisconsin's 2020 election
audit report and this is just the
beginning other swing states are even
far
worse
um is this what trump is relegated to
now because he's not on twitter like is
this is this just a guy clinging to the
last
gasps at attention someone sent me an
interesting clip yesterday
and it was a clip of
this hard right young right winger nick
fuentes
and even fuentes was saying
this is a weird period for trump and
he's kind of struggling for relevance
i actually think that that's
an understatement but accurate he's
struggling not only for relevance but
he's even struggling to maintain any
kind of
presence
in national media now that doesn't mean
we count this guy out if trump is due
well in 2022 and trump's healthy going
into 24 he very well may run now i know
when i spoke to michael cohen cohen said
i don't think trump will run because
he's not going to believe he can win and
trump doesn't want to lose again that
may be
but it remains to be seen
um so just absolutely pathetic
unhinged posting posting posting to this
thing what is trump even doing all day i
do often wonder we've got a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p this
is really funny
this is a joke voicemail but it's nicely
done
yesterday we talked on the show about
the uh oratory skills of former
president barack obama in the context of
campaigning for
tech virginia gubernatorial candidate
terry mcauliffe here's a funny caller
who says now obama wasn't that great of
a speaker at these events take a look
hi david i really don't agree with your
assessment of barack obama as a great
orator
he didn't fart he didn't talk about
toilets
belittle the holocaust
i really think uh rudy giuliani trump
and taylor green are much better orators
right no it is true there was no
discussion at all of uh plumbing we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
elements of bathrooms people are
flushing toilets ten times fifteen
pounds okay
that last one still gets me uh no it is
true uh as far as we know barack obama
had no flatulence
events like rudy giuliani
he didn't trivialize the holocaust like
marjorie taylor greene he didn't talk
about plumbing the way donald trump
sometimes does we're going to be
covering these last few
terry mcauliffe rallies joe biden's
going to be out with him maybe barack
obama will be back out with him again
tonight in fact biden will be out with
mcauliffe and mcauliffe's opponent glenn
younkin
has a rally so today
we will be live streaming and i think
it's an important race virginia
gubernatorial but very well said by the
caller on today's bonus show
democrats suing the postal service why
we will tell you
does the irs really spy on your bank
account this is a new right-wing idea
and um is there any truth to it or is
there no truth to it are they going too
far what's the what's the truth we'll
talk about it
and there's more and more pressure in
the aftermath of the alec baldwin
disaster where alec baldwin accidentally
killed someone on set
last week uh more pressure to just not
even have real guns on hollywood sets at
all we're going to talk about that on
today's bonus show as well get instant
access
by signing up at joinpackman.com
we will see you on the bonus show in
near moments
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman